vous promener à dreux vous remarquerez
des herbes hautes à certains endroits et
des plantes récemment entretenu à
d'autres c'est ce qu'on appelle la
gestion différenciée des espaces verts
le parc du quartier débattent en est un
exemple un choix assumé de la
municipalité le but préserver la nature
face au réchauffement climatique pour
ramener cette biodiversité c'est
vraiment très important de ne pas tondre
en plus c'est une protection sur la
tonte des herbes c'est à dire qu'on la
protège en était plus elle sera rasent
plus elle va être tondu courte plus elle
va cramer facilement elle va attraper
des maladies le fait qu'ils aient la
biodiversité qu'une façon moins de tonte
il y a plus de fleurs plus de fleurs dit
plus d'insectes plus d'insectes dit plus
d'oiseaux inauguré fin 2019 le parc
louis philippe est un poumon vert de 7
hectares en plein coeur de la ville
les drouet viennent s'y promener et se
défouler je marche tous les jours ça
fait du bien et adler ya il ya des
espaces et à tous et à des arbres aires
de jeux et équipements sportifs ici
petits et grands cohabite avec
l'écosystème grâce un entretien
différencier la faune et la flore
sauvage reprennent en partie leurs
droits au parc débattent fauchage tonte
et désherbage sont réalisées en fonction
des types d' espaces naturels sur ce
parc on a différentes classifications on
a de la classification type iii comme
vous pouvez le voir sur la gestion
différenciée avec des zones de fauche on
est sur les espaces en amont sur une
classification tuto 2 avec des
fréquences de tongs qui ont être de deux
à trois semaines et c'est ces
différentes zones en fait qui vont
permettre de déterminer et de dire que
cette gestion différenciée ne dis pas
que l'on abandonne un espace où qu on ne
l'entretient plus on le gère juste
simplement différemment dans le cadre de
l'aménagement du parc des arbres
fruitiers ont été plantés bientôt les
passants pourront venir y cueillir des
fruits mais quelques années de patience
encore avant de pouvoir y goûter